はじめ）よしっああぁ　よしー！
たなっち）はじめさん今日は勝ちますよ
は）今日は…
は）めっちゃ緊張してんだよなぁ
は）いや、勝つよ今日は　た）うん
は）悪いけど
た）本当に
は）去年は2回戦まったんだよ（？）待って…
は）おい本名本名
た）大丈夫っすｗｗｗ
（ビリッ）
は）あ、ヤバイヤバイ
た）はははｗｗｗｗ
は）去年は2回戦で負けたんで
は）今年はそれより多く行けるようにちょっと
は）頑張りたいと思います
は）まぁ貴様らが辿り着けなかった領域に
は）俺はいってやんよ
た）いやーでもそれもあれですよ
た）はじめさん今日1回戦で負けたら
〉え、俺たちもですか？
た）うん
皆）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は）1回戦負け引退？
た）はじめさんが1回戦負けで引退
は）とりあえず俺はちょっと優勝する気できたんで
は）こう、今日は　行きます
た）忘れ物ないっすか？
は）多分ないと思う　た）はい
は）オッケーオッケ大丈夫　デッキもっ
は）デッキさえあればなんとなるところあるから
は）オッケー　た）紙持ちましたか？紙
は）持った持った　た）サイコロとコイン
は）行きます　た）はい
は）さー着きました
は）ちょっと小さめの会場ですが
は）頑張ってきます　では
た）デッキありますか？　は）ある
は）ほら
た）ほんとだ
〈はいーいきますー坂東さんとー堀塚さーん〉
は）はい
〈2018年の6月に開催される日本代表決定戦に出場する権利を得ます〉
〈制限時間終了時点でライフポイントの優劣があっても、そのターン終了まで継続する〉
〈そのターン終了時点で勝利が確定してなければ……〉
〈よろしいですか？〉
一同）はい　は）はい
〈はい、それではお願いいたします〉
〈よろしくお願いします〉
一同）よろしくお願いします
は）さいしょはグーじゃんけんぽいあいこでしょ
は）先攻で
は）たってやったぜー
は）やばくなかった？
た）いやぁ〜〜〜
た）すごい辛い試合でしたね
は）1回戦目から延長入って
は）ライフポイントが微量の差で勝ちました
は）もう無理もう無理
た）やーやばい結構しびれました
は）もうダメ　た）俺最後のヴェーラー結構
は）感動した？　た）感動した
〈お願いします〉
は）お願いします
は）さいしょはグーじゃんけんぽいあいこでしょ
は）はい
は）見てたか…
た）ガバガバすぎ
は）やらかしにやらかしを
た）やらかしにやらかしを重ねてた
えー
東海予選　静岡県の代表を決める県大会ですね
えー2回戦で
ありがとうございました｡ﾟ(ﾟ´Д｀ﾟ)ﾟ｡
何やってんだ俺
もーもういいです
僕のことはもう罵ってください
2年連続できてあの場であのミスをするのは
本当にバカ
もったいねーなぁー
まぁ一応参加したんでこういうね
2018年のなんか世界大会のスリーブはもらいました
いやーもうもったいないの一言に尽きるんすけど
まぁそこも含めてのまぁ遊戯王なので
仕方ないなとは思っております
言い訳とかっていうわけじゃないですけど
ちょっと始めるのが遅かったなっていうのを
思いました…
やっぱ結局ね遊戯王っていうのはね
あのコツコツと毎日ちゃんと
やってる人が勝つんですよ!
結構直前ねめちゃくちゃ朝までやったり
練習しまくったんですけど
やっぱりまだ時間が足りなくて
あのーそういうミスが起きてしまったのではないでしょうか
まぁやっぱあとは緊張かな
まぁ正直もうなんかたるんでた部分があって
反則負けしたのかなと思います
まぁなんか反則負けなんですね
その故意的ななんかズルしてやろうと思って
やったやつじゃなかったんで
なんかその一発退場みたいな訳じゃなかったんですけど
結果的にもう戻れないんで
それでもうどうしようもないねって言って
負けちゃったって感じでございます
まぁ最後ああいう県大会の場で
あのギリギリでも勝てたんで
よかったです
はぁ…
できれば優勝したかったあああ
ゴンッ
えー、一勝だけでもすごいことだと思うんですけども
まぁ反則負けしたのをもったいないなっていうか
極度のきんちゃ、緊張に弱いんすよね
緊張するのが嫌なんすよ
去年と同じ場所で止まっちゃったんですけども
逆にいうと去年より下がってないんで
まぁプラスに考えて
来年も機会があれば頑張りたいと思っております
見ました？動画の顔
ずっとこうやって見てますからね腕組んで
って感じのすごいピリピリした戦いが
すごいあの癖になって楽しいです遊戯王
来年も頑張ります!!
とりあえず違反しないようにしよう
じゃーな
（はじめん頑張れ！来年は世界大会出場だ！）
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
がんばれ！